environ 1300 fauteuil neuf salles et un
grand groupe de cinéma ugc
voilà ce à quoi devrait ressembler le
nouveau multiplexe de plaisir débuté en
juillet dernier le chantier du nouvel
équipement avance bien et n'a presque
pas subi la crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui toutes les cases iman toutes
les salles sont terminées avec les
écrans de poser les fauteuils il nous
reste encore deux salles où il faut
mettre les fauteuils notamment avec les
fauteuils et adultes et enfants dédié en
même temps maintenant il reste la
peinture duo le montage des caisses
définition on est vraiment rentré dans
la dans la phase de finition du cinéma
le chantier s'est très bien déroulé
malgré tout la conjoncture coe j
et c'est donc naturellement avec tous
les protocoles de sécurité qu'on a dû
mettre en place pour les ouvriers pour
que le chantier semaine à bien mais tout
s'est bien déroulé et c'est pour ça
qu'on est à peu près dans les temps pour
le futur cinéma à plaisir installé en
plein coeur du centre commercial mon
grand plaisir
le nouvel établissement viendra
compléter l'offre culturelle de la
commune l'unique cinéma avait fermé ses
portes en 2008 à plaisir nous n'avons
pas d'autres cinémas on faisait le
cinéma en plein air pendant l'été
puisque avec le département dans le parc
du château on avait ça mais on n'avait
pas d'autres salles de cinéma 9 salles
c'est exactement ce qu'il nous faut mais
je pense qu'on va rayonner bien au delà
plaisir parce qu'on a pas mal de deux
villages autour de plaisir qui attendent
aussi cette ouverture de cinéma si la
fin du chantier est prévue pour la fin
du mois de mars
rien n'est moins sûr pour l'ouverture
officielle qui dépendra des conditions
sanitaires